you say surround yourself with people
who you genuinely
because if you're shooting feature film
you're going to spend so much time with
you know and it's so tense i always have
the feeling is like going to war I've
never been in a war that that's what I
imagined it to be and they will see you
at your lowest at your most desperate
and I feel the most scared you've ever
been you know and you really are I at
least maybe that's a personality thing I
just need a network of people that will
support you emotional giving away from
their craft and away from how good they
are but people that I'm happy to see in
the evening after shooting for 12 hours
you know and someone who's just my
cinematographer for example there will
be at the end of the day every shooting
day there is that one moment where he's
starting to pack up and I'm done and our
eyes will meet and I know from his
expression if we had a good day or not
you know it is not a very emotional guy
so there's a slight twitch of a smile
and if I get that I know this was a good
day doesn't matter how much other people
are talking and this was great Bubba I
don't care I care about that one twitch
you know and it just emotionally means
more to me and I can relax and I know it
went well from his side and things we
got good stuff and my editor is almost
more Tara pissed than an editor you know
she's Indian that she has the whole calm
quiet the big picture of you that I
don't have because I get obsessed and
everything suddenly met her so much and
sealing shield suddenly get on the phone
for
in our because someone in India has a
sore throat and I'm like does it matter
you were making a movie isn't this more
important and she's like no it's not and
she's right it's not yeah she's just
she's bringing this calm at this hall i
don't know i don't think i would have
met any of the two movies that I've made
if it hadn't been for that symbol of her
and editor you know because they are my
closest friends and they bring this
peace and quiet with them and also they
make me remember that we're not going to
die if this movie doesn't turn out well
you can only work so hard on something
and they'll still be my friends even if
this movie doesn't become a success so
that's important at the other thing is
that ideas don't necessarily always come
in the hours between nine and five so I
want to be able to call someone i'm
working with at midnight and saying what
do you think about this
yeah with people that I'm friends with I
can do that with the Senate Oliver that
we just hire our team probably say what
the hell are you doing calling me at
midnight give call tomorrow but then
that spark is gone so there's just an
intimacy if you surround yourself with
people at you but you love
you